CORRESPONDENT, JONATHAN MARTIN
IS BACK WITH ME.
JON, THAT CAMPAIGN AD IS ONE --
ONE OF THE MOST MEMORABLE OF ALL
TIME.
DID ANYBODY SEE THIS COMING?
THIS -- THIS SUDDEN SCHISM
BETWEEN TWO MEN WHO HAD SO MUCH
IN COMMON?
>> UH, YEAH.
I THINK THE LAST FIVE YEARS OF
POLITICAL HISTORY OF DONALD
TRUMP WOULD SUGGEST THIS WAS
PROBABLY INEVITABLE, GIVEN THAT
BOTH OF THEM HARBOR POLITICAL
AMBITIONS.
LOOK, TRUMP CLEARLY HAS DESIGNS
ON BEING PRESIDENT, AGAIN.
I THINK DeSANTIS IS WIDELY
ASSUMED TO HAVE WHITE HOUSE
HOPES, HIMSELF.
SO, YOU KNOW, AS BIG AS THE
STATE OF FLORIDA IS, IT'S NOT
BIG ENOUGH TO CONTAIN BOTH MEN.
POLITICALLY AT LEAST.
SO NOT -- NOT TERRIBLY
SURPRISING.
BUT THOSE CLIPS WERE FANTASTIC
THAT YOU PLAYED, ERIN, BECAUSE
THEY REALLY GET TO THE KEY ISSUE
HERE WHICH IS I THINK TRUMP
FEELS A LEVEL OF BETRAYAL.
HE FEELS LIKE HE MADE RON
DeSANTIS.
YOU KNOW, FOLKS DON'T FOLLOW
FLORIDA POLITICS SUPERCLOSE
DON'T REALIZE THIS.
HE -- RON DeSANTIS WAS BASICALLY
A BACK-BENCH HOUSE MEMBER, NOT
TERRIBLY WELL KNOWN, RUNNING
AGAINST A VERY PROMINENT
STATEWIDE OFFICIAL IN ADAM
PUTNAM.
AND HE WAS -- HE WAS NOT GOING
TO WIN THAT PRIMARY UNLESS AND
UNTIL TRUMP ENDORSED HIM.
AND TRUMP DID DO JUST THAT, AND
THE REST IS HISTORY.
SO I THINK TRUMP FEELS A SENSE
OF POLITICAL OWNERSHIP OVER THE
GOVERNOR AND -- AND THE FACT
THAT HE IS NOT FEELING THAT
RECIPROCITY RIGHT NOW IN TERMS
OF, YOU KNOW, THE GOVERNOR NOT
BEING WILLING TO SAY I WON'T RUN
FOR PRESIDENT IN '24 IF YOU RUN
THE RACE.
I THINK HAS STUNNED TRUMP.
>> SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S
INTERESTING.
DeSANTIS'S STATE OF THE STATE
SPEECH JUST A FEW DAYS AGO IN
FLORIDA, YOU KNOW, DID CHECK
ALL
THE BOXES AS YOU KNOW, JONATHAN.
IF YOU ARE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2024 AS A REPUBLICAN.
HERE IS A FEW CLIPS.
>> FLORIDA IS A FREE STATE.
FLORIDA IS A LAW-AND-ORDER
STATE.
WE WILL NOT ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE DEFUNDED.
I PROPOSE AN ELECTION INTEGRITY
UNIT, WHOSE SOLE FOCUS WILL BE
THE ENFORCEMENT OF FLORIDA'S
ELECTION LAWS.
>> SO, MAJOR GOP DONOR WHO IS ON
THIS SHOW FREQUENTLY AND I KNOW
HE TOLD YOU, QUOTE, HE IS TRUMP
BUT A LITTLE SMARTER, MORE
DISCIPLINED WITHOUT BEING TOO
BRUS.
THE THING IS, THOUGH, WHICH IS
AN INTERESTING THING.
HERE WE ARE.
RECENT REUTERS POLL SHOWS 54% OF
REPUBLICANS BACK TRUMP.
11% DeSANTIS.
SURE, IT'S EARLY.
HOW DOES DeSANTIS CHANGE THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF HE DOES,
ERIN.
I MEAN, THAT'S THE THING.
I THINK DeSANTIS IS KIND OF
LIKE -- TO BORROW A SORT OF
SEASONAL METAPHOR HERE, KIND OF
LIKE ONE OF THOSE NFL TEAMS THAT
NEED SOME LUCK TO GET TO THE
PLAYOFFS.
HE NEEDS OTHER THINGS TO HAPPEN
TO GET A PLAYOFF BERTH AND I
THINK THAT PROBABLY INCLUDES
TRUMP EITHER NOT RUNNING OR
BEING, YOU KNOW, SERIOUSLY
WEAKENED POLITICALLY A YEAR FROM
NOW.
AND I TAKE IT THAT THAT'S, RIGHT
NOW, NOT LIKELY TO HAPPEN.
I THINK THAT'S THE SCENARIO FOR
DeSANTIS IS HE NEEDS SOME HELP.
HE NEEDS SORT OF TRUMP AS THE
OBSTACLE TO GET OUT OF THE WAY.
BUT THIS GETS TO THE HEART OF
THE FRUSTRATION THAT PEOPLE,
LIKE THE GOVERNOR AND OTHER
FOLKS IN HIS GENERATION
POLITICALLY IN THE GOP, FEEL.
WHICH IS, YOU KNOW, THEY -- THEY
BELIEVE 2024 IS EMINENTLY
WINNABLE AND THAT JOE BIDEN IS
POLITICALLY WEAKENED BUT THERE
IS REAL FRUSTRATION -- THEY
WON'T SAY IT PUBLICLY AT LEAST
RIGHT NOW BUT THERE IS REAL
FRUSTRATION AMONG THAT CROWD,
UM, IN THE GOP THAT, YOU KNOW,
TRUMP IS STILL IN TH